هذه ليست مشاهده لتعذيب احد المجرمين انها
طقوس اعتياديه للعلاج على يد هذه الفتاه
العشرينيه التي تحولت الى مقصد علاجي شهير
في بوركينا فاسو يتوافد اليها الاف السكان
لطلب العلاج والاستشفاء وجلب الحظ
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منا
عالم غريب
في قريه توجين بيلا الواقعه على بعد 30
كيلومترا جنوب مدينه وجادوغو عاصمه
بوركينا فاسو
منذ طفولتها كانت تدعي بان لديها قوى
خارقه تتمثل في بعض الرؤى والاحلام
الغريبه لكن والديها هاجماها واتهمها
بالجنون
قوه
في انحاء البلاد في صباح الاحد من كل
اسبوع طوابير طويله من السيارات والدراجات
الناريه تقل الاف المصدقين بالقدرات
الخارقه لانجاه الذين تزين معظمهم بملابس
بيضاء اللون
امواج من البشر بينهم رجال قيدت اقدامهم
بالسلاسل واخرون يقولون انهم ممسوسون او
اصيبوا بالشلل والعنوب سوء الحظ او
تطاردهم الارواح الشريره جميع هنا ينتظرون
خروج ايجاب من مقرها لتقرا عليهم ادعيتها
او تمنحهم بعض العلاجات والادويه
الماء
لا تتقاضى اي اموال نظيره خدماتها وعلاجها
بالمجان تماما لهذا زادت شعبيتها وسط
مجتمع فقير كما ان مرضاها اكدوا على
قدراتها العلاجيه
لا والله ارد
شاركونا ارائكم هل تصدقون روايات وجود
اشخاص يمتلكون قوى علاجيه خارقه